de rire en deuil
louis de funès est mort la nuit dernière
invité de ce journal l'autre comique
français admiré par de finesse coluche
le président mitterrand au maroc long
tête à tête aujourd'hui avec le roi
hassan ii pas d'objection de principe à
la fourniture de centrales nucléaires
françaises situation débloquée à la
régie renault reprise du travail à flins
négociations à billancourt la campagne
des municipales jacques chirac paul
quilès et jacques toubon une partie de
cache cache ce matin dans le 13ème
arrondissement
madame monsieur bonsoir les malheurs les
gens les retrouve bien assez tôt le rire
on en aura toujours besoin
c'est ce qu'aime est à dire louis de
funès l'acteur comique le plus apprécié
des français
l'homme dans les grimaces les
ricanements et le rire fit rire et
feront rire encore des millions et des
millions de gens louis de funès est mort
la nuit dernière à nantes des suites
d'un accident cardiaque il avait 68 ans
il avait été victime d'un premier
accident cardiaque en 1975 et depuis il
vivait le plus possible dans son château
de clermont près de nantes où il aimait
taille et les roses louis de funès qui
s'était donc en pleine gloire son
dernier film le gendarme et les
gendarmettes date de quelques mois
louis de funès avait tourné plus de 100
films avant de devenir vers 40 ans une
immense vedette populaire la carrière sa
carrière émaillée de quelques morceaux
de choix georges les goûts ah les belles
bacchantes et les spectacles
branquignols de robert dhéry ont été les
premiers pas vers la gloire
puis au théâtre il y eut le grand succès
d'oscar qui deviendra un film de bolides
à eau
vous êtes allé chercher ses bijoux et
vous verrez qu'au cateau de fiançailles
alors de cette façon sa mère ne pourra
plus rien vous croyez en 1964 jean
giraud qu'il avait déjà employée dans
huit quick va offrir à de funès le
premier film de la série des gendarmes
c'est l'explosion de sa popularité
oui dix ans et voilà c'est parti il a
suffi que je sois là
ouais
sus aux dunes
quelquefois on disait mais n'est pas
commode non non c'est un homme qui était
très très timide et à leurs oeufs si
vous connaissez pas bien ils avaient ils
avaient ils avaient eu peur ils avaient
peu il avait une panique mettez qui vous
connaissait bien dès que vous deveniez
un ami alors c'était un enchantement
parce que chaque minute cet homme
voyez quelque chose de drôle que vous
n'aviez pas perçu et il voulait vous
transmettiez alors ' bon pleurer de rire
avec lui je connaissais comme homme et
c'est un homme c'est lorsqu'il était à
l'aise qu'ils étaient vraiment très
jeune et charmant simple avec moi avec
les gens aimant la vie du pays
il était un de vos fidèles à l'open du
paroissiens c'est sympa rochette dont
les autres et très fidèle lui c'est un
chrétien il pratiquait régulièrement
élèves une fois très profonde
gérard oury à l'idée d'associer de funès
à bourvil en 1965 le succès du corniaud
est prodigieux il y a là un couple de
comédiens dont le jeu se complètent
admirablement
vous n'avez pas assez de se pourvoir
devant la red bull c'est pas grave
qu'est ce que je vais devenir mois
entier tomber plus vrai mais mes
vacances au futur appartient pour
l'italie prenez l'avion qui l'a plus dit
plus et vous serez comique ça vient
comique des situations
saleh s'est elle acquit la situation
c'est toujours les la plus grande
situation du monde c'est un monsieur qui
lit son journal avec une chaise
quelqu'un s'approche en ue une bombe là
dessous élites ont des pages il n'y a
pas et je voudrais arriver à faire un
film comique à biot un film un film muet
mais c'est très difficile à effet mais
pas muet comme du temps du muet muet
avec tous les bruits les sons mais où
les gens s'ils n'ont pas parlé et qui y
mangent pas comme les mots qui parlent
d'autres au bourg de soké en 1967 la
grande vadrouille battra tous les
records de recettes c'est sans doute
pour de funès le sommet d'une carrière
qui compte une centaine de films de
valeurs très inégale
bah merde vous demandez toujours sa
joyeuse avec nous j'avais la langue bien
pendue bon sens reprenons numéro 17
oui café ça c'est moi veut et où vous
croyez vous opéra butt la maison
chauffée méphisto marguerite faust sorte
et je ne veux personne dans la salle
lorsque je travaille je ne veux que
perdu aux émois et parmi les grands
succès de louis de funès l'ale ou la
cuisse un film de claude zidi qu'il
tourna en 76 avec un homme qu'il
considérait comme l'autre grand comique
français cet homme c'est vous coluche
vous vous le trouviez drôle louis de
funès
bah oui ça oui tout le monde le trouve
drôle d'ailleurs ça a été un vrai
problème parce que maintenant que ces
films vont passer régulièrement à la
télévision va falloir s'arranger avec
les enfants parce que quand c'est un
jour pas ouvrables pour le lendemain il
faut que les enfants voient quand même
le film sans ça c'est un drame ou à la
maison
vous n'allez tourné qu'un film avec lui
oui j'ai tout risqué même film mais vous
aviez l'étranger ensemble
eh ben on avait on avait dit qu'on fera
un retour on avait signé un papier sans
valeur autres que celles qu'on peut lui
accorder nous mêmes mais on avait on
s'était signalé par disant voilà bon
pour un film qu'on fera tous les deux
rigolos et il parlait tout à l'heure de
faire un film muet et c'est c'est ça
qu'on voulait faire pour un film muet
mais presque finir alors son talent à
lui louis de funès par rapport aux
vôtres
c'était quoi bonne question était
meilleur que vous a sûrement oui
ah oui moi je sais bien en tout cas que
quand j'ai travaillé avec lui il voyait
bien que j'avais pas faire le métier
quoi parce que ça s'apprend vis pas
comme ça aujourd'hui même j'ai fait lui
film peu près donc j'ai pas j'ai pas
d'expérience mais à l'époque c'était un
des premiers quoi alors il voyait bien
et il m'a tout de suite il m'a tout de
suite indiqué les deux trois trucs qu'il
fallait pas faire et qu'il fallait faire
il était drôle il était gay
dans les rapports quotidiens oui il
était gai oui enfin moi quand je les ai
connus dont qui je suis sûrement celui
qu'il connaît le moins bien de ce qui
pourra en parler mais ça vous êtes là je
sais pas où et pourquoi pas face je suis
une fan d'en parler mais c'est un homme
rigolo charmant on m'avait dit une
réputation épouvantable
il est très méchant il va te mettre de
dos il sera de face dans le champ et
dans le contre chant au fur et à mesure
que tu parles y tourner
et puis après ça si toute façon si t'as
pas eu au tournage et aura au montage
parce qu'il y passait en fait c'est pas
vrai céret le charmant et qui a demandé
à ce que je partage l affiche en vedette
avec lui alors qu'il n'était pas obligé
mais dans la veine comique qui
l'exploitait la caricature du petit
français râleurs ricanant un peu rhin 6
parfois très courtisans des puissants et
puis aussi tyrannique avec les faibles
c'est pas un pull à la même veine que
vous c'est toujours le même sujet un
très long c'est toujours le sujet qu on
exploitera simplement comme le bonhomme
qu'on chérit change au fur et à mesure
de des années eh ben on en change quoi
mais c'est tout en fait c'est toujours
la même chose mais c'est sûr autrement
dit nos moeurs à tous
oui bah oui c'est de ça que les genres
il plus quoi c'est de l'or défaut quand
on leur montre coluche merci louis de
funès sera inhumé demain dans son
village de la loire atlantique
le ministre de la culture jack lang lui
rend hommage mais aussi monsieur madame
giscard d'estaing en hommage à louis de
funès antenne 2 diffusera mardi prochain
au cours de l'émission mardi cinéma le
film de gérard oury le corniaud ou louis
de funès partageait la vedette avec un
autre grand disparu du comique français
bourvil film dont vous venez d'ailleurs
de voir un extrait le conflit à la régie
renault semble en bonne voie de solution
après l'accord intervenu la nuit
dernière sur l'ensemble de la politique
salariale pour 83 les grévistes de
l'atelier de peinture de flins ont voté
cet après midi la reprise du travail à
billancourt
les négociations se poursuivent à flins
cet après midi les journalistes ont eu
maille à partir avec les grévistes qui
reproche à la presse d'avoir politisé et
islamisés le mouvement de grève
c'est pourtant bien l'analyse qu'en fait
le premier ministre pierre mauroy dans
une interview à nord éclair
les immigrés sont agités par des groupes
religieux et politiques en fonction de
critères ayant peu à voir avec les
réalités sociales françaises déclarent
en effet le premier ministre le climat
cet après midi à flins et les réactions
syndicales à la reprise du travail
michel perron par 107 voix contre 29 les
ouvriers de l'atelier de peinture de
renault flins ont donc décidé de
reprendre le travail dès 15h cet après
midi à l'origine de ce vote positif
un accord salarial global pour
l'ensemble de la régie renault signé
hier soir par la plupart des syndicats
et la direction
cet accord prévoit pour l'ensemble du
personnel une augmentation de 8% pour
l'année 83 à laquelle s'ajoute un
supplément mensuel de 40 francs un petit
coup de pouce de 80 francs pour les bas
salaires plus un autre de 155 francs
pour les pistes aux lecteurs de
l'atelier de peinture
tout cela a débloqué la situation
pourtant des problèmes restent encore en
suspens notamment ce qui concerne les
évolutions de carrière et les conditions
de travail
la direction s'est engagée sur beaucoup
de points dans les conditions de travail
notamment dans la cabine de peinture qui
était un peu vétuste et elle s'engage à
la refaire dans les plus brefs délais
elle s'engage aussi avec le robot qui
avait été dit qu'ils étaient
inutilisables et qui gênait beaucoup
dans ce secteur elle s'engage à le
retirer dans les plus brefs délais aussi
dans les autres conditions de travail
elle nous a promis qu'elle qu'ils
allaient regarder de très près et nous
croyons que ça va être fait dans les
plus brefs délais nous pensons que si
les réponses ne sont pas données sur les
questions qui restent en suspens à
propos de l'évolution professionnelle et
bien d'autres conflits sont susceptibles
à moyen terme au plus long terme de se
reproduire
quant à la déclaration du premier
ministre affirmant que les immigrés sont
habités par des groupes religieux et
politiques les syndicats la récuse avec
force
nous nous portons complètement faux
devant de telles assertions les
travailleurs immigrés de flins on menait
d'élus de ces dix dernières années en
1973 en 1978 en 1982 et puis maintenant
en 1983 il ya quelques années on
employait pas du tout ce type
d'arguments aujourd'hui on le met en
avant ces luttes sont dans la continuité
les unes par rapport aux autres et donc
nous comprenons mal comment on peut à
l'heure actuelle le
prendre ce point comme étant un des
points capitaux explicative des lieux de
travailleurs immigrés manifestation cet
après midi dans l'usiné talbot de poissy
quelque deux cent des ouvriers mis en
jeu aujourd'hui en chômage technique par
la direction à l'appel de la cgt de la
cfdt protester contre cette mesure
un autre conflit social qui se politiser
qui met en émoi la presse
un conflit qui dure depuis quinze jours
le confit de l'union de reims ce journal
prise en main par un directoire de la
cgt directoire qui hier je vous le
disais censurer un éditorial du
rédacteur en chef
le gouvernement est sorti de son silence
aujourd'hui et condamnent je cite les
actions illégales du livre cgt
le communiqué de l'hôtel matignon assure
que le gouvernement mettra tout en
oeuvre pour maintenir l'existence du
journal sans pour autant se substituer
je cite toujours à une direction
défaillante ni aux organisations
syndicales responsable de conditions
poursuit le communiqué de matignon
le rétablissement immédiat et général et
intégrale de la responsabilité des
journalistes dans le confident le
contenu rédactionnel du journal et le
respect de la décision de justice qui a
nommé un administrateur judiciaire
l'historique du conflit pour une eau le
dreff la crise de l'union de reims prend
donc un tour nouveau
hier la cgt a censuré un éditorial du
rédacteur en chef et l'a remplacé par un
communiqué elle comprend le journal
depuis le 14 janvier dernier
ce jour là la cgt avaient séquestré
certains gérants légaux du quotidien
plus tard elle les en avait chassé
désormais les ouvriers du livre
interviennent directement sur le contenu
du journal et ne tolèrent plus de textes
qui leur déplaisent
ils rentrent ainsi le compromis respecté
jusqu'à présent dans leur relation avec
la rédaction
dans le communiqué paru ce matin la cgt
dénonce je cite une partie des
journalistes qui a rejoint le camp de la
droite dans son combat pour conquérir le
journal la rédaction se trouve divisée
devant cette situation nouvelle
une partie des journalistes déclarent ne
pas accepter le coup de force de la cgt
l'autre partie continue néanmoins à
travailler mais depuis ce matin il n'y a
plus de rédacteur en chef à l'union de
reims estimant que je n'avais plus
depuis quelques jours les moyens
matériels de réaliser la réaction comme
elle le devait ce soir ce que pour la
qualité rédactionnelle il été vues dans
des conditions morales valeur ses
habitudes été censuré la partie par le
fait que je me trouvais donc exclue
donné par gatti en tant que journaliste
et un temps correct en chef et qu'en
conséquence jusqu'à retour à une
situation légale interlocuteur légal je
m'estime et 1000 entreprises
quant à l'administrateur judiciaire
récemment nommé par le tribunal de
commerce
il n'a même pas pu pénétrer dans les
locaux un groupe d'ouvriers lui en
interdit toujours l'accès les relations
entre la france et le maroc sont au beau
fixe le président mitterrand a eu cet
après-midi long entretien en tête à tête
avec le roi hassan 2 sur le chemin de
rabat à marrakech
dès hier soir le chef de l'état français
avait donné à son hôte un gage de
l'intérêt que la france porte à
l'amélioration de ses relations avec le
maroc en levant tout obstacle de
principe à la fourniture de centrales
nucléaires de rabat bernard pradines aux
320 km aujourd'hui pour le président
mitterrand et le roi hassan ii de rabat
à marrakech
en voiture puis en train et tout au long
du parcours à chaque arrêt dans les
villages du sud marocain l'entousiasme
les pétales de rose ou le lait de
chamelle et l'offrande des dates dans
l'entourage de monsieur mitterrand après
une première journée de visite qualifiée
de très positive en insiste beaucoup sur
la qualité des rapports entre les deux
hommes les entretiens ont été des
personnels et approfondie dans le train
royal pour la deuxième moitié du
parcours
le président français et le roi hassan 2
ont encore eu le temps d'approfondir
leur dialogue qu'on peut dire pour
résumer de toutes les portes sont
ouvertes
le maroc voudrait l'assistance de la
france pour construire des centrales
nucléaires
il peut produire la matière première
d'uranium dérivé du phosphate réponse de
monsieur mitterrand pas d'objection de
principe
sous réserve du respect de la
réglementation internationale et des
contrôles dans ce domaine n'y
participerons à vos études car il est
logique qu'un pays comme le vôtre
cherche à assurer son indépendance
énergétique
cette question difficile est un exemple
de ce que pourrait être une coopération
adapté bien sûr rien n'est fait mais on
parle de projets économiques agricoles
universitaire et financier l'arrivée à
marrakech a été spectaculaire les images
de cette deuxième journée sont
significatifs de la volonté politique
exprimée d'aller encore plus loin que
prévu en matière de coopération
les négociations sur le désarmement de
l'europe viennent de reprendre à genève
est à vienne
et ce soir une confirmation de
washington washington rejette une
proposition soviétique que le
gouvernement américain qualifie d'
irréaliste la proposition d'une zone
dénucléarisée en europe centrale au même
moment le ministre français de la
défense charles hernu réaffirme
l'indépendance de notre défense
nucléaire
cet après midi au plateau d'albion
monsieur est venu à visiter les
nouvelles installations des missiles
dont la force française est maintenant
équipé les missiles s-300 revue de têtes
multiples et doté d'une puissance de 1
méga tonnes
soulignant l'importance de cet effort de
modernisation des forces nucléaires
françaises monsieur hernu a aussi
précisé la position de la france dans
les négociations en cours
non
mais les grands surarmés on le sait
voulait prendre en compte nos forces
nucléaires nous français nous ne
l'accepterions pas mais tout ce qui
pousserait aujourd'hui la france vers la
structure militaire intégrée de
l'alliance serait coupable de
déséquilibre donc de crise dans quel
état se trouve réellement anatolie de
france qui le mathématicien juifs
soviétiques que vous voyez ici filmé
clandestinement il ya six ans avant son
arrestation pour dissidence et son envoi
dans un corps de travail ou deux puis
suit une longue grève de la faim
sharansky selon monsieur andropov aurait
cessé sa grève de la faim
c'est en tout cas ce que le numéro un
soviétique a affirmé à georges marchais
qui lui avait demandé des précisions sur
le sort du mathématicien sa femme est
arrivée à paris aujourd'hui et devant
moïse berthet elle a aussitôt cherché à
joindre sa belle mère à moscou
ce matin nous avons assisté une
conversation téléphonique entre la femme
de stars en ce qui est la mère du
mathématicien qui de moscou lui a lu le
texte d'une lettre qu'elle a envoyée au
comité central du parti communiste
soviétique
madame ida stans qui at elle entendu
parler de la lettre de monsieur bros
fois femme monsieur marché oui on lui a
dit mais elle ne peut comprendre comment
monsieur andropov a pu écrire un tel
message
elle ne peut l'imaginer image cochée ce
but elle est sur place elle connaît la
situation les autorités soviétiques lui
ont fait savoir qu'elles natoli n'est
pas à l'hôpital parce qu'il fait la
grève de la faim le 14 janvier elle reçu
l'aide d'anatolie qui lui dit exactement
comment il va bien sûr il va mal après
quatre mois de grève de la faim si je
peux envoyer une lettre dit il à sa mère
c'est que je reste et c'est ma grève
elle n'a pas reçu de lettre et il y a
déjà un an qu'à nathalie et l isolement
ok tu espérais vous qu'il va cesser sa
grève être transféré à l'hôpital il le
faut autrement je ne sais pas ce qui
peut arriver il faut le spitz alizés
immédiatement d'après ce qu'il dit lui
même il va très mal
après une statistique
le comité de défense de transe qui
souligne pourtant que la lettre de youri
andropov un jour je marchais reste un
élément d'espoir
la campagne pour les municipales a donné
lieu aujourd'hui à paris est l'un de ces
chassés-croisés qui prouve bien que le
talent politique c'est aussi l'art de
provoquer ou de fuir certaines
situations le xiiie arrondissement de la
capitale où s'affrontent le social le
rpr jacques toubon et le socialiste paul
quilès qui dispute la mairie de paris à
jacques chirac le 13ème arrondissement
était très fréquenté ce matin dans un
des marchés du quartier jean louis le
scène et jean-michel mercurol ont
assisté à une scène que je vous laisse
savourer 9h30 le premier jacques toubon
le candidat chiraquien dans le xiiie
arrondissement arrive au marché bobillot
il attend de pied ferme son adversaire
paul quilès 9h45
arrivé du 2e paul quilès pas de
rencontres prévues dit il il tourne le
dos à jacques toubon
mais la partie de cache-cache ne durera
pas longtemps
alors président
avoir visité les pyrénées-orientales
en 10 manches à rien moi je me suis
débarrassé les gens sur un plan
politique
et bien pas démagogique vous qualité
arguments personnel sont les seuls qui
soient mais différenciée au comme vous
êtes un homme de droite
les arguments que vous utilisez en
permanence et je vous lis avec plaisir
ici et là des jolies votre maître
monsieur chirac
moi j'ai un tac pas les hommes je parle
des idées je parle du xiiie
arrondissement que je connais où
j'habite langage le résoudre les
problèmes les atteindre langage les
événements dans tivoli civique
vous n'avez aucune occupation que de
curer ziem un tremplin politique
10h05 voilà le troisième jacques chirac
prévenus à temps arrive dans le quartier
mais sur un autre marché
son seul but c'est vrai le maximum
demain dans le minimum de temps mais
surtout sans rencontrer son challenger
socialiste je lui même il faut pas
démérité les visions comprenez que
d'immédiatement ça bouscule tout le
monde
une bonne excuse car dès qu'on apprend
l'arrivée du candidat socialiste ce
remède marché le maire de paris
s'engouffre dans sa voiture et disparaît
quilès n'a pas pu éviter de rencontrer
tout bon mais le débat avec le maire de
paris n'était pas pour aujourd'hui
je voudrais bien que monsieur chirac
s'explique un petit peu c'est facile à
faire des monologues facile de lancer
des anathèmes
mais sur les vrais problèmes de paris
c'est ça qui est en cause à l'occasion
des élections municipales il va bien
falloir que l'on discute
une chose est sûre tout bon le contre
face à face avec qui il est ce qu il s
ne pense qu'aux face à face avec chirac
mais jacques chirac lui avec qui
accepteraient ils de se mesurer
comme quoi les parties de cache-cache
c'est aussi de la tactique électorale
municipale encore sachez comment malgré
les recommandations du parti socialiste
d'appliquer l'accord d'union avec le
parti communiste les socialistes locaux
ont décidé à l'unanimité de présenter
jean claude boulard contre le maire
communiste sortant robert jarry sachez
aussi qu'à lyon sept membres du rpr dont
5 figurait sur la liste du candidat rpr
michel noir ont rallié la liste du maire
sortant francisque collomb un sondage
enfin publié aujourd'hui par un groupe
de journaux de province 40% des français
contre 36 sont mécontents de la présence
de communistes dans le gouvernement
la france verte a voté aujourd'hui trois
millions et demi d'exploitants de
salariés agricoles et les organisations
professionnelles ont désigné leurs
représentants au sein des syndicats
agricoles et donc décidé de leur
importance relative
on connaîtra les résultats demain à
l'adouber ce qui a observé le scrutin à
cergy dans le val d'oise ce matin une
mairie de village en france quelques-uns
des trois millions cinq cent mille
électeurs qui étaient appelés à
renouveler complètement les 94 chambres
d'agriculture cette année un décret à
changer le mode de scrutin de ces
élections de majoritaire il devient
proportionnelle départemental de listes
au plus fort reste
ce mode de scrutin permet l'apparition
de nouvelles sensibilités
si le rôle des chambres de commerce
n'est contesté par personne
dans un monde rural partout sur ses
gardes
la réforme concernant ces élections
provoqué aujourd'hui bien des
grincements de dents autour des urnes
nous avons de plus en plus l'impression
que cette élection est une élection
politique
pourquoi parce que jusqu'à l'été jusque
maintenant entière et maintenant elle
est à la proportionnelle ce qui est en
brouille un peu les choses et nous
obligent à vraiment étudié le problème
et être tout à fait au fait de la chose
dans l'esprit du gouvernement cette
réforme a un but connaître de façon
précise les agriculteurs et les
organisations part à l'école non
répondent certains électeurs de la fnsea
ce scrutin à la proportionnelle n'est
destiné qu'à affaiblir la fédération a
contesté sa représentativité résultats
définitifs dans quelques jours a voté
une histoire de l'intérieur gaston
defferre veut envoyer en haute garonne
et dans les alpes-maritimes préfet
spécialement chargé de la police il a
annoncé aujourd'hui en réponse un cri
d'alarmé des députés socialistes locaux
qui s'inquiètent de l'efficacité
relative du travail de la police dans la
région
réaction du député maire de nice jacques
médecin c'est une mesure dirigée contre
le préfet actuel des alpes-maritimes en
corse un un tournant semble-t-il dans la
position du flnc maintenant clandestins
dans une conférence de presse la nuit
dernière près d'ajaccio
des représentants du mouvement
indépendantiste ont affirmé qu'il ne
s'agissait plus pour eux de revendiquer
pour la corse
l'indépendance pure et simple mais je
les cite une sorte d'indépendance en
fait une autonomie très large assez
proche des thèses d'edmond simeoni et de
l'union du peuple corse
le 51e rallye de monte carlo s'est
terminée ce matin sur la victoire du
champion du monde l'allemand val terol
sur l'ancien l'écurie lancia sort
victorieuse de l'épreuve malgré quelques
émotions dans la journée puisqu'il était
question de déclassement en rival eagle
il ne fallait pas attendre grand-chose
la dernière nuit du rallye de
monte-carlo avance des lancers de balle
terreur mais de markku alen était telle
que sauf incident ou accident
les hobbies ne pouvait plus espérer les
rejoindre de fait dès la première
spéciale disputée dans le col de la
madone valter earl annoncé la couleur et
réalisé le meilleur temps c'est
cependant une autre lancia qu'elle et
faire le spectacle pendant la nuit grâce
à jean-claude en plus l auteur de six
victoires sur dix en épreuve spéciale
en arrivant à monaco ce matin à bâle
terreur ne pouvait donc se féliciter
d'un troisième succès en principauté
succès remporté avec brio
la joie de l'allemand ne les entend pas
duré longtemps au cours des
vérifications techniques effectuées
après l'arrivée on s'assurer de la
conformité des voitures
les commissaires laissé entendre que les
l'ancien pourrait être disqualifié en
raison d'un réservoir et de tubulures
jugé non conforme
finalement et après de très longues
délibérations qui se sont terminées il y
à une demi-heure environ
les l'ancien était officiellement
déclaré conforme le doublé val terreur
les maroua l'année donc confirmé
heureusement d'ailleurs car on ne voit
pas quelle satisfaction réput irait
leurs adversaires d'un succès obtenu sur
le tapis vert
la domination de valve terreur les de sa
voiture ayant été tel en effet qu'elle
ne mérite aucune discussion le football
et la corse en deuil claude papi
l'ancien capitaine de la glorieuse
équipe de bastia est mort subitement cet
après midi d'une hémorragie cérébrale en
jouant au tennis
il avait 33 ans claude papi avait été
trois fois international et fait partie
de l'équipe de france pour la coupe du
monde de 78 il y aura un tiercé de ma
vincennes les pronostics de pirate
bresse vous allez les voir le 17 le 14
le 15
le 12 le 13 le 16 le 8 et le 7 est
maintenant le temps pour demain philippe
dumez oui bien c'est toujours un temps
très doux mais toutefois il sera un peu
plus pluvieux et vous allez le voir sur
notre photo satellite ceci est dû au
fait que l'anticyclone qui protège notre
pays s'atténue légèrement et donc va
permettre aux nuages qui viennent du
nord de pénétrer sur la moitié nord de
notre pays ceux ci est envoyé
l'anticyclone ici si l'anticyclone le
fameux anticyclone des açores
eh bien il nous amène de l'air chaud
depuis l'équateur et la frite et ceci
est canalisée par cette dépression qui
se trouve au dessus et arrive
pratiquement directement sur notre pays
ce qui nous amène toute cette douceur
donc pour demain nous allons le voir sur
notre cas c'est toujours à peu près le
même temps un temps clair et ensoleillé
relativement au sud avec toutefois des
brouillards de l'aquitaine au centre et
puis un temps beaucoup plus nuageux au
nord avec quelques pluies et des vents
qui vont soeur
renforcées sur toutes les côtes de
l'atlantique et de la manche
et puis alors des températures et bien
disons le exceptionnelle de 10 à 16
degrés sur tout le territoire vous voyez
que c'est tout à fait agréable
alors pour demain et bien c'est la fête
des gildas et puis le soleil se lève à
8h27 pour se coucher à 17h41
voilà à 22h55 claude sérillon vous
présentera votre dernier journal avant
de nous quitter jusqu'à demain batteur
une rectification c'est le mardi 8
février et non mardi prochain au temps
pour moi que nous diffusons sur antenne
2 le film le corniaud avec louis de
funès et jusqu'à demain soir je vous
propose de rire une fois encore ensemble
de rire avec louis de funès
bonsoir à venir
je crois qu'il veut vous embrasser je
vous entre le double de four chambre et
en peluche -0 gentes au bénin
va-t-il pas à vous faire
à
et